that's not normal
alright brother I love I'm not gonna
burn things all this time wait no wait
come back here you [ __ ] well that's an
easy way to get a vasectomy
Oh every guy out there is like cringing
right now every time oh right between
the legs that's not good that's not good
Oh escape now from what I don't exactly
see a threat here dude babe oh let's go
down this way
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh no all right oh
no my son is dead whatever am I gonna go
well good thing I just got an instant
vasectomy with a katana my nards flat Oh
God machete anyways you think you're in
pain look at me I have an axe for a tail
now holy crap get out of my way you kid
bastards don't care you're not my son
you don't look like things like me
oh god damn it no crazy course how crazy
was talking like psycho bonkers crazy or
just to all god damn longest bottle run
if you say so
Wow that was hard
rooftop madness he is the target well
what about this guy oh god damn it
well here I go anyway charge suck on
that [ __ ]
pardon me oh I shall use this blade Oh
how's it going there oh we just share an
intimate feel oh god damn it it's
attached to my wiener my new best weapon
rather narrow am I still alive we're
gonna do it one more time but you gotta
have a one okay okay
the head of my child is no good come on
point one percent impossible well that
doesn't seem that impossible actually oh
don't - murder I can't all right kids
will go on an awesome adventure here and
hopefully it won't be like like that
like any family who was like lost on my
proposing how am I gonna finish with
with all of these old man titties
there's a problem here there's leaves
you a better Santa clothing operation
going on and we need to kill all the
sinner
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today want to help the channel
grow
leave a like add it to your favorites
will share with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video